Hello. My name is George Stagg.
I'm an open source software
engineer working in the
tidyverse team for Posit.
I'm the lead developer
of the webR project.
And today,
I wanted to make a video
to talk about some of the changes
in, webR 0.2.0. So, if you
don't know about webR, it's a
version of R compiled
for WebAssembly,
that can run in
a web browser,
and other web assembly
environments such as node.js.
So this is probably my favorite
quick example of what webR can
do. This is a code block with
some R code in it, in this case,
a linear model done in
base R. And if I hit the run
code button, you can see that
R code is run, and
the results shown to
you on the screen.
And the important part about
this is that there's no R
server running to
execute that code.
That code is being executed in
the web browser directly on this machine.
This is live, and interactive.
So I can change it.
I can produce a
new R code and run it to get
to get real interactive live
results. And then that
also includes plotting. I
can plot images there, all
directly in the web browser.
So you can imagine, the
applications that this opens
for uses of R on the web.
And the ones I'm most
interested in are things like
educational content.
So interactive documents and
presentations like this one,
and an educational doc,
content, including even
things that are documentation.
And then,
whereby having those tactile
interactive examples directly in the
webpage. And I feel really
helps with with those use cases.
Another thing we're beginning to look
at is the idea of containerization
of an R application
and, in sandboxing,
and taking some R
application
and being able to run it in
its entirety on another machine
through the idea of
portability and distribution of
of WebAssembly apps.
I am also aware of one
application, one person using
webR as a way to access
R on a tablet, in this
case, they're they're running
webR in a web browser,
through their tablet.
On a device that otherwise
wouldn't be able to access on.
So, as I say, webR, version
zero two zero is now available.
The top link shown there is
a demo, webR REPL application.
REPL stands for read, eval,
print, loop and it's
another name for the R console
that I'm sure you're
familiar with. If you're
a JavaScript developer,
you can install webR
through NPM, or you can,
run it directly from CDN.
And the documentation to
integrate webR into your own
programs is that
that URL there.
So let me talk
about the updated,
webR REPL application
but before I do that, I'll
just talk about the changes since version,
zero one one webR.
So, we updated the
source version of R from,
I think it was R four one
zero to four three zero.
We've changed the
package name from
r dash wasm slash web r,
this, the sort of namespace package,
just to the webR package in
npm, makes it a little easier to install.
And we've rebuilt the
demo application, using a more
modern framework we've we've migrated
from using jQuery to
the React framework.
We've expanded the
functionality of the in-browser
canvas graphics and
bitmap graphics systems.
And we've made improvements
to accessibility and
internationalization in
those graphics systems.
And we're supporting,
lots more R packages,
which I'll talk about
in a separate video.
Something else, I'll talk
about in a separate video is,
the changes to
the developer API,
And if you want to
read more about that,
you can also read the
NEWS document inside the webR repo.
So let me talk about the, webR REPL app. So it looks like this,
and you can see if you
saw the previous version of the REPL
app, it looks a bit
different. As part of the redesign,
into the React
framework we've expanded
the view so that
there's now this,
editor in the top left corner, so
I can type R code in here and
you get, code suggestions and
syntax highlighting,
all built into this
code mirror code editor.
The nice thing about this is
that you can also save the
files directly to the virtual
file system that webR is
running in, which it takes
me to this panel here.
This is the
file system viewer
built into webR,
it's been expanded to have more
controls at the top to manage
files and directories on
that virtual file system.
And the view itself,
the component,
implementing that tree
of directories has been replaced
with a component,
a React library,
designed to build an
accessible tree view component.
So that, users who,
browse the web through
keyboard only, for example,
are able to
use this component, effectively.
The console is, as it was
in the previous version, the main
difference between the previous version,
and this is that it
has a feature enabled that
allows users to use screen readers,
to read the input and output
of that console. So if you're doing some
kind of analysis or in my case,
just generate some
random numbers,
the previous version of
this component,
that those results were
not accessible to things like
screen readers, but
here they are. So again,
users with accessibility
issues
who need to use those tools are
able to use the R console in
this webR app effectively.
And then finally, the last,
panel is the plotting,
panel. So if I
run a command to
produce some plots,
and this is using a
built in graphics device into webR,
and up calling the
canvas graphics device.
It's drawing
those plots using a
a web API known
as canvas graphics,
and you can move
through plot history and
save plots into a bitmap file or
or clear them directly from this page.
The final thing I'll say
about the editor is that,
you may have noticed
earlier that as I type,
code suggestions
are produced.
This is using a feature built
in to the code mirror editor
that, we've hooked
up to R's built-in code
completion engine.
And that means it's,
context aware of the
code you're typing. So if I type sample here,
then, s i z,
you can see it's suggesting
the argument size to me,
and that's because the
code completion generator knows that
size is an argument to
the to the sample function,
which is really nice as
you're writing code to have
those suggestions given,
that intelligently like that.
So that's the REPL application.
I'll move on now to talking
about the HTML canvas graphics device,
which I briefly showed
in the lower portion of the screen.
So the canvas graphics device
is built into the webR
application and allows you to
render graphics in the web browser.
We've made big improvements,
since the last release,
by moving from
the canvas API to
to this off screen canvas API.
So here's a video of producing
a plot with three hundred
thousand points from the
last version of webR.
You can see it's quite slow.
The reason for that is
because each of those points
is drawn by sending a
message from the worker thread where
computation happens and in the
web assembly environment to the
main thread where that
that plot is being drawn.
So dispatching and handling all
of those messages for each of
those points separately,
creates a big overhead and
that's what the main cause of
those performance issues were. In
the latest version of webR,
it's much improved.
It's an order
of magnitude faster and it's all
thanks to this this
off screen canvas API.
What it does is it lets us
draw the image on the worker thread
and then just send a single
message with the finished image
to the main thread to be shown.
Using off screen canvas
has enabled us to enable,
much more advanced
text rendering features too.
We can now take advantage
of text rendering provided by the
web browser that
webR is running in.
So here's an example
of some code, again,
running live in this slide.
Showing off some of
those advanced, text features.
The biggest benefit of this
is probably that webR now
supports much
better, international
scripts when, plotting.
So you can see there's
some Arabic text here,
some Hebrew and
some Japanese, and they're all
handled, automatically now by
the webR canvas graphics device.
That font
fallback that enables this,
also allows you to use emoji
in your plots should you want to.
The nice thing about the
canvas graphics devices,
because we're relying on
the web browser to plot,
to draw those graphics,
we can actually use font files
that are installed on the user's
machine. You can use system
fonts. So here, for example,
I have, family Future as the
title, but I can change that.
I can say, Helvetica if I wanted to.
And this provides not only
a benefit to
internationalization for all
those alternative scripts,
but also accessibility because there
exist some fonts that are
designed to help users with,
reading barriers
such as dyslexia,
to be able to,
comfortably read text,
so there's an OpenDyslexic
is such a font.
You can see that if I
rerender that image,
that that font is now being
used for the, the title and
the X and Y labels.
So those users who prefer
to read text with
that font are now able to do
so in webR should they wish.
In addition to the
canvas graphics device,
webR also has updates to
support the standard bitmap
graphics devices
built into R.
So if you're running in a
browser that doesn't have,
if you're running in an
environment that's not a web
browser, such as
node server side,
or you're running a R code
that isn't aware of the canvas
graphics device, you can now
do so with webR. So here,
I have an example that this
is just loading webR into the
page, and then there's,
some R plotting code here,
writing a png to to the
virtual file system.
And,
once that png has been written
to the virtual file system with
webR, there are file system
APIs that lets you read that
file into a
JavaScript variable.
And once you have that
data in JavaScript,
you can do what you
need to do with it.
You can you can offer it
to the user as a download,
you can display it in the
page or if you're running server
side, you could send that
data over the network.
The way this works,
is that we've compiled
the cairo graphics library and
pango text layout engine,
to WebAssembly as part of
the webR build process.
And by compiling,
compiling those libraries to WebAssembly and linking them in,
we can enable those advanced
text features that I already
talked about for the
built in graphics devices,
as well as the
canvas graphics device.
The main difference between
the two is that for built-in
cairo graphics with
with png, for example,
those fonts, can't be read
off the user's file system.
And instead, they must be
provided to cairo, through the,
through the webR
virtual file system.
So webR ships with a
minimal selection of Noto fonts.
But if you do
have other requirements for different
scripts or different font typefaces, you
can upload those fonts to the
virtual file system,
and webR has been configured
to search that directory
home/web_use/fonts, for
font files and use them.
So here's an example,
very similar to a previous
example I showed you.
The only difference is this
time it's creating a png file
instead of displaying
it in a browser,
and you can see the results
are very, very similar.
And all those text, features
that I talked about things like,
ligatures in Arabic text and
the font fallback for different
glyphs.They're all
supported, including,
the the right to left text and,
various other features.
This works, in this
example, because I've uploaded some
fonts for those alternative
scripts to the virtual file
system in the in
the correct place.
And webR has automatically then
used them to produce this plot.
So,
the last thing I want to
talk about in this video is,
something we're calling the
lazy virtual file system.
So everything I've shown you
so far comes with a price.
Increased WebAssembly
download size, data size,
if you're bundling fonts,
they'll have to be downloaded
but not every user will
want all of those features.
So not every user will
want to use cairo graphics and download
those font files.
Some people would just
want to do some computation and
and return some numbers.
The same thing applies to
files built into R already.
So R ships with lots
of documentation and examples and datasets.
And they're not necessarily
needed for every user.
So it'll be nice if webR only downloaded the data it actually
needs to run your R code.
And webR 0.2.0
does just that. It uses
an API provided by emscripten for their,
for their file system
environment. That, allows the
file system to only download
the files when they're requested.
So here, in this example, I'll
just open the dev tools,
and you'll see exactly what I
mean. So if I refresh the page,
you can see the R
files are downloaded
to run R and its base packages.
But then if I run the command
png to use cairo graphics
to build a bitmap
graphics image,
you can see it's only at
that point that those cairo
libraries are downloaded to
the device. And this,
and a similar thing, if
I plot something now,
and I draw some text,
you'll see that the font files
are only downloaded at the
point of actually producing that plot.
So if I don't use cairo graphics
and produce a plot that
requires those fonts, they won't
be downloaded by the user.
That's really nice because
it reduces the initial download
size of webR by a lot.
For the application
that I've been showing,
the demo REPL app,
in the previous version of webR
with less features that was
forty megabytes of download.
In the new version, it's
only nine point five megabytes,
and that's with
the extra features.
So that's only
twenty three percent
of the previous download size.
So that's a really
good improvement for
the download size
of it of an initial webR
loading, of the engine
into a page.
So that's everything I wanted
to talk about in this video.
Do try out the app,
and see you run
your own R script.
And if you're a
developer, as I say,
you can install webR
from NPM or CDN,
and the documentation is
shown there on the screen of
that URL. Do go and read
the documentation if you,
if you want to try webR
on your own applications,
because there are some
subtleties when it comes to,
when it comes to putting
those applications on the web.
If you do create something
interesting with webR,
please let me know. My email
address is shown on the
screen, and I'd
love to hear about it. And,
thank you very
much for listening.